I am pissed you know why I'm pissed
because I am an American I am an
American citizen with an American
opinion on what is happening right now
and there are millions of Americans like
me that are furious at this genocide we
are Furious and we are Furious that the
United States is paying for these bombs
we are Furious if you go to to Orthodox
Jews we are required to let the world
know that these zionists and their state
does not speak for the Jewish people
Muslims were protecting the churches
holding the keys Abid Judah he's
entrusted with the key to the Church of
the Holy sear it is one of the holiest
sites in Christianity and its key
belongs to a Muslim family is
unfortunately it comes down to one of
the core principles of Islam be like
Muhammad sallam assalam Alum greetings
of peace my name next guest Imam Tam he
holds a ba in Political Science And a ba
in Islamic law he's here to bring us up
to speed on what's going what's
happening in the world are we headed
towards it's scary to say World War I as
an American we want to know is this good
is this actually good for America let's
bring out our guest Imam Tom this
the I love you the work that you're
doing when I was ready to talk about it
I would only talk to
was expain how much respect I have for
the faith of
Islam how you doing Imam alhamdulillah
I'm doing good how about yourself see
alhamdulillah that's like Hallelujah is
it all praise to God yeah that's right
yeah now people hear Imam Tom they're
like hold on when we hear Imam we should
it should be like Imam Abu baka or Imam
Muhammad how's it come Imam Tom that's
like a American name yeah just like you
got Eddie right yeah I mean that's you'd
have to ask my parents that's what they
named me right so it's true though I
mean uh people have the impression that
uh Islam is something foreign that is
something that belongs to Arabs or
people from Asia and uh they don't
realize that Islam is a universal Faith
right that it appeals to lots of people
all over the world and that it's
actually directly um purposed for that
it's purposed and it's built to be
Universal for all places and for all
times so we shouldn't be surprised when
we see uh Tom or Bob or every Tom Dick
and Harry that are that are Muslims now
um because you know we have a lot of
people accepting Islam from all walks of
life what does Islam mean and what does
a Muslim the word Muslim mean yeah Islam
is surrender to God right and submission
to what God wants you to do um now that
creates an imperative right that creates
an action point you have to go and
figure out what God wants you to do do
um and so you have to evaluate like what
okay does God communicate to us does he
is he um does he have so much good will
and love for us that he bothered to
guide us you know the answer I would say
is yes right we believe that God is sort
of a compassionate loving merciful god
then he would have made an effort or an
attempt to guide us well then you have
to look through okay well what are all
of the claimants to represent God's
guidance or Allah's guidance and then
you have to sift through
are which are true and which aren't true
because some people get it wrong they
they say well X sort of claimant this
claimant over here to they say that they
represent God's guidance but it's got
this problem and that problem and then
they throw out the baby with the bath
water and they say that well that means
that none of them they're all the same
and that's not true you actually have to
go through and determine for yourself um
there's internal and external ways right
is it coherent does it sort of make a
certain amount of sense uh then there's
also external ways is it preserved can I
trace it back to its Origins to the
prophet that it it supposedly is
ascribed to and if you go through all
that like I did then you find that the
Quran is the only intact and and
preserved Revelation and communication
from God and so what you need to submit
and surrender to God and and to do what
he wants is found in the Quran so this
is uh something that you know when you
hear it makes sense okay Imam Tom he's
doing Islam and you went and defined it
it's submission to the will of God and a
Muslim is one who submits his will to
God so it's not now they have these
terms that they throw with it you think
okay Muslim and they think some Arab in
the desert Islam some backwards cult you
know and they they associate it with
some terrorist terrorist organizations
uh have you SE have what's your response
to that yeah I mean the there's
political reasons why that that
narrative has been pushed right I mean
there's no if you go before Islam and
Muslims were Public Enemy Number One in
the west and there were others right you
go back to uh you know the movies where
there's Russian terrorists and then
there's movies where there's you know
this type of terrorist or that type of
terrorist these are narratives that are
pushed because there's big money to be
made in war um because there's resources
there's territory there's lots of things
that people in power want and so they
need a bad guy right and so the bad guy
right now is is Islam and the Muslims
it's very lucrative people make careers
people are put on speaking tours people
are given lots of money um to supposedly
spread their uh their half-baked non-
expertise about Islam and the Muslims
and and how bad we are I like that Half
Baked yes uh tell me this uh so you have
um so it's opposite to what we're
hearing there's a very popular
Conservative Christian radio host and
political commentator by the name of
Charlie Kirk H what caught my attention
with him was he was on the pbd podcast
not too long ago before all of these
things erupted and he was actually
talking about like many Christians about
working together with Muslims because of
the whole alphabet movement the
sexualization of children and they were
really respecting how Islam was holding
on to these Traditional Values while
many were just buckling they were
compromising he recently put out a tweet
it's a long one I was quite taken back
and and I mean I don't
people who know him say that he's I want
to give him the benefit of Doubt because
he was trying to work with us so I'm
trying to see if we can make connections
with people like he can connect with
people like you and other community
leaders because it seems like he's
regurgitating things that have been
passed down to him from much of the
islamophobia industry so I'll focus on a
couple things here uh in his tweet and
he tries to lump all these different
political groups and everything inside
to the definition of what a Muslim is so
I'll read out a couple of things from
his tweet he says unfortunately it comes
down to one of the core principles of
Islam be like Muhammad sallam take
slaves rap rape young girls kill people
in
robberies yeah well that's nonsensical
right so this is somebody who is relying
upon old orientalist probably you know
um crusadememes
or misrepresentations of Islam and then
you know he's become an expert I guess
overnight about what Islam is uh so
that's I guess would be my first
response is that this person is a very
very poor understanding of Islam and
it's easy to cherick things that you've
heard from the islamophobia industry
that supposedly was happening uh at the
time of the Prophet wasallam or by the
prophet Sall alaihi wasallam himself and
then just quickly move to Isis this
group that group which is I read the
tweet and that's exactly what he did the
underlying assumption is that they're
assuming that groups like Isis
accurately represent Islam and then they
are basically sort of uh looking back in
time and trying to make a connection
between the two right which is something
that is nonsensical anybody who has just
a basic weekend school education in
Islam knows enough to be able to dispel
those myths but you know it's it's
difficult to if we're going to give him
the benefit of the doubt when there's
things are unfolding in real time and
this is the miseducation that you've
been given that this is all this person
has to draw off of um when in reality
you know probably a more honest and and
moral and virtuous disposition would be
to say well actually I don't really
understand very much about what Islam
actually is I hear a lot of conflicting
things and I would like to be put in
touch with people who maybe could
educate me um because I've only heard
sort of one side of it unfortunately
unfortunately there's sort of a conflict
of interest that a lot of people who are
public figures experience where
everybody's looking you to speak on
everything um sometimes you're monetized
and you have a monetary incentive to
speak on things that are going to get a
lot of clicks and then you get this as a
result so anybody like this I mean just
because we've had lots of success on the
ground level with people who are not
super famous who have similar takes they
have similar assumptions about what
Islam is and then if you're able to have
a relationship with them and put them in
touch with somebody who actually is
worth their salt um with Islamic
scholarship can go in these things in
detail and explain and then people have
turned around entirely and people have
actually accepted Islam so you know that
would be the best case scenario and we
hope that Allah guides this person and
puts him in touch with with somebody who
can provide that for him because
obviously you really I mean took a deep
dive your story now for somebody an
American your Christian background is
that right yes yeah I was Christian for
most of my upbringing and then I was an
atheist as a teenager okay now if if
Islam was really promoting what he's
saying in the rest of his uh tweet he
talks about
that that is why your doctor colleague
or neighbor is not a bad person they're
decent people precisely because they are
bad Muslims who are not really following
Prophet Muhammad so the the takeaway is
like okay they're okay because they're
Half Bake Muslims they're not or you
know they're not really fully ba you
know following Islams but if they follow
Islam they follow muhammmad peace be
upon it's going to be a problem yeah
well you can't just cherry-pick right
and that's why you know people are just
taking little you know have truths or
quarter truths and then ripping them
from Context and then you know expanding
and and blowing them up and if the shoe
were on the other foot look we could do
the same if you claim to be a Christian
I can go into your Bible I can find
quotes or I can take things that
Christians have done and I can say well
this is what Christianity is and if
you're not doing the same thing then
you're not a true Christian if a man
beats his male or female servant with a
rod so that he dies under his hand he
shall surely be punished not withstand
if he remains alive a day or two he
shall not be punished for he is his
property you believe Charlie this is
justice that a Slave be beaten male or
female so bad he dies a day later and
there's no punishment because that slave
the property of somebody else I believe
that you believe that you need to get
out of this conversation right let's go
into the Crusades and how Christians
treated other Christians when they
sacked Constantinople and killed the
Orthodox Christians that lived there
because they weren't part of the right
sect or when they took over Jerusalem
and slaughtered babies and slaughtered
women and they expelled the Jews again
because the Christians remember that
when they ever take over a place they
expel the Jews that's a problem that
Christianity and Christian European have
had right um You know that if you're not
expelling the Jews from the United
States of America then you're not being
a proper Christian right so Two Can Play
That Game right but I don't think that
they'd be willing to uh to submit to
that sort of logic if it was turned
around on them yeah that's a good point
that's very important like if we're
trying to uh you're trying to um build
Bridges you're trying to develop
understanding you're sincere you don't
come off as insulting you don't come on
like you said you can go into the Bible
and you can quote Genesis you can go
ahead and you know talk about let's say
this the thing was reversed and you
start coming in and saying look all
Christians are if they follow the Bible
they're going to be incest driven and
then you give the story of lth with his
uh two daughters incest right we're not
trying to offend no Christians right but
I mean you can go you can go really deep
and you could take this far and then
you're throwing stones out of a glass
house where you gonna get with that
that's my point where are you gonna get
with that right you are you gonna get to
a common good and fight off a common
enemy and you're you're not I mean what
do you that's that's the point that I
don't understand yeah no I completely
agree I completely it's not an
exploratory attitude people think that
they already know I would tell that if
anybody wants to understand something
then you need to adopt an exploratory
attitude if you think you already know
then no one has anything to teach you
yeah and then uh you can't you can go
you can go you can really go like um I
give this example often like if you want
to be deceitful you want to you want to
play this game like in the Bible where
it says uh where Jesus if I give my own
interpretation I say look you know
Christians they're uh people who want to
put the sword to your neck they're not
uh they're not F the prince of PE would
you love Jesus obviously they they say
uh Jesus said I've have not come to
bring peace but a sword right so they
want to bring the sword to your neck but
then what is the the actual
interpretation of that it's a metaphor
right yeah no 100% and that's something
I've said you know in conversations with
non-muslims I don't necessarily expect
you to like me or to like Islam or to
like Muslims but just be consistent you
know like if be consistent if we're
going to apply the same tactics and the
same logic on you you would reject it
out you know completely categoric so
let's be real yeah that's you don't want
to be hypocritical here yeah and then
these things I was looking at the part
where you know this whole uh if you
contextualize many of these things
obviously rape if the Propet didn't
allow a woman who was to be slapped
would he allow that woman to be raped
there were a group of companions Seven
Brothers they had one slave girl she
used to cook for them yeah the youngest
of them brothers got angry one day and
he slapped her okay she came to the
prophet PE upon him and she said that
this person slapped me so the brothers
came they came to the prophet and they
said you know our youngest brother got
angry and he slapped they didn't mean to
do it they were apologetic what what was
the prophet's ruling um to not hit free
her free her free her what just
immediately immediately now I'm asking
you a question just from the just from
that slap because of a slap I'm asking
you now we're establishing criteria here
I'm asking you a question if the proper
didn't didn't allow a woman who was to
be slapped would he allow that woman to
be raped 100% I mean this just like come
on we we're I was thinking like we we as
Muslims we we have the thing of the the
second gaze the second look right you're
not even trying to you know you're
trying to lower your gaze when you're
seeing a woman let her alone you're not
even talking about you know out of
respect uh a man is not even shaking
hands with the opposite gender unless
his mother andt someone in the family
let alone you know something that's uh
we call zad to to go ahead and right
this is like how where did where do you
think they got this where did they get
this this is like right well I mean
that's the thing and here's here's
another thing that I think that people
need to realize when these sorts of
comparisons are made that a lot of times
people project and we've seen this
recently with the IDF and the Israeli
Zionist regime where you know people
have have have caught on right and
they've said that every um accusation is
a confession right we we see this a lot
where you know like what's what's the
society that has a problem with its
soldiers raping people uh the United
States military has a problem with that
and that's well do doed the IDF has a
problem with that and that's well
documented right so again as you said
people in glass houses shouldn't throw
stones right if we're looking at at what
is going on here let's look at what your
Society does and the people that you
support do and we're not granting we're
not agreeing with their analysis but we
can easily make such a caricature right
of everything that they hold near and
dear and everything that they support um
but that wouldn't be honest of us right
so we just ask people to be consistent
and there is nothing that they can bring
to go ahead and substantiate the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessing be on doing
something like that no of course he had
the LIE he had the LIE when he said that
you know he basically was referring to
the marriage of AA which was completely
consensual and culturally you know
normal Aisha was engaged to someone
before the prophet Muhammad s wasallam
um and then was broken off after Islam
came um and then you know she they were
completely in love for their entire
lives and after he passedat you know she
you know was so devoted to him you know
um is this what rape looks like you know
anybody who has any degrees in
Psychology or expertise in in what rape
actually is would say no this isn't at
all right so now here's a problem with
modernists and liberals is that they
don't really necessarily have any fixed
values or virtues right they don't have
any sort of strict thing to go off of so
they're just very very ready they're
almost allergic to people in the past or
people who live in more traditional ways
ready to see them as backwards and
barbaric and things like that not
realizing that many of the values that
they have are probably worse right than
whatever they're trying to sort of cast
on us right why should you're for many
people that are Christians in America
you let your daughters and your sons
have boyfriends and girlfriends and and
sleep around outside of marriage and
have children out of marriage and out of
wedlock um and this is this is somehow
good this is somehow virtuous this is
somehow better right there's tons of
things um that are culturally acceptable
in contemporary us culture that are
Abominations and other absolutely
horrible um so let's let's compare
apples to apples right A lot of times
there's sort of this it's sort of like a
condemnation right and we've we've had a
lot of conversations in the Muslim
Community since the escalation in
Palestine um about the
how how it's a deflection tactic to get
us to condemn right and this is another
this is another deflection tactic to get
us to condemn you Muslims do this you
Muslims do that first of all you're
wrong second of all you start condemning
I can come up with a whole list of
things that you need to condemn about
what your Society supports or what your
religion supports or what you even you
support yeah it seems like they get you
now on the defensive and you're trying
to you know go ahead and answer all
these things and like you said ear if
you're sincere no problem someone like
that can go ahead and you're you're an
Imam in what uh City UDA udica New York
UDA is he welcome or someone like him at
any time we make the connection he can
come in sit with you you make know
you're very busy you make time for
someone like Charlie to sit answer all
his questions Char's question 100% put
the cameras away like just let's sit
down oneon-one and that's that goes to
anybody I went on conservative talk
radio here locally and I you know
sparred with the guys there and at the
end of the conversation I said the same
thing if you want to come and you have
questions and you're exploratory and you
actually want to understand you come and
visit and you give me a call or you or
you talk to me and we'll actually have a
conversation but a lot of this stuff is
just
grandstanding you hear that Charlie look
he's inviting you to his mosque I'm sure
many other imams would you can invite
him on your program and let's have a
talk let's have a
dialogue um one last thing here is
interesting what do you think he meant
by kill people in robberies like I don't
know I think he was really grasping I I
think he was you know again these are
just orientalist tropes about how Islam
is sort of like a violent religion like
like Warlords and you know sort of
expanded By The Sword all of which has
been debunked you know the work of
Richard bullet is really important to
showing how the spread of Islam um was
actually something that took a lot
longer than people thought uh even
though the political boundaries expanded
very rapidly that they left intact local
government structures and local
religious culture and these sorts of
things so this is just it's just
orientalist tropes thinking that you
know the early Muslims were just this
band of you know of Bandits just robbing
people at sword point or something like
that now again if we want to put the
shoe on the other foot who does that who
threatens to take away Aid money if you
don't support the US and their You Know
cover for genocide in in Palestine you
know let's talk about highway robbery
like I'm I'm sure if we were to put the
shoe on the other foot people will get
uncomfortable real quick um but you know
many people aren't willing to be honest
like that let's get into now what is
going on all these sad uh events that
are unfolding I mean you have what
what's the current count now how many uh
innocent civilians uh have been over
8,000 I mean it's absolutely absolutely
tragic and completely unnecessary um and
has exposed sort of the um I think the
unsustainability of the occupier state
that is Israel and the entire situation
um it's been exposed on live TV multiple
times what their genocidal intentions
are what the regime is calling for is
nothing less than wiping out a people um
and so people uh uh unfortunately
Muslims understood right away that this
was what they were going for non-muslims
took a little bit longer but even
they're starting to see and understand
that this is something that has nothing
to do with Hamas it has nothing to do
with terrorism it has nothing to do with
uh defense it has nothing to do with
proportionality it it's absolutely just
the naked land grab and dispossession
and extermination of a people it's
something that has been planned
something that has been intended for
decades it's been going on for decades
though less acutely now that it has be
got has become very acute people are
starting to wake up and see what's
really going
on I want to get your reaction to this
Christian actually who's calling out
other Christians and we need more people
like this to speak up here in the United
States the Christian zus Movement John
haggy go down the list of them Perry
Stone Lance wnow Steven Strang at
charisma you go down the whole list of
Zionist puppets are clapping and
cheering for this atrocity they're
delighted I mean this is just so
incredibly disingenuous on their
part be peacemakers why why aren't they
calling for peace why aren't they
negotiating why aren't they putting
pressure on Israel you have to stop
treating the Palestinians like they're
animals you say you're the children of
God but you treat the Palestinians like
their rats why aren't these Christian
leaders telling the Jewish Zionist this
is ungodly you say you the chosen people
of God you can't behave like this yeah
that's great we need more people like
that I mean unfortunately I mean power
powerful huh very powerful why aren't
they calling for peace he's saying
Charlie why aren't you calling for peace
well Christians have a reckoning in the
United States they have to reckon with
the fact that a lot of them have sold
their religion for politics a long time
ago um so when it comes to you know
selling out to the Israeli Lobby or
selling out to the neocon platform or
selling out to whatever it is you know
you know there's um there's a large way
in which Christians especially very
influential Christians in the United
States have to reckon with this
nationalism what's truly your religion
right are you truly dedicated to the
United States and its foreign policy
interests and its sort of support for
genocide abroad or are you dedicated to
God which one is going to work which one
is has priority for you is it one nation
under God or is it one God under a
nation you have to decide a lot of
Christians unfortunately haven't gone
through this Reckoning but uh late's
better than never and I think hopefully
people are starting to recognize that
this is something they have to seriously
think about is this good you're an
American I'm an American born here this
what's happening now in Israel uh this
attack on the innocent civilians you
have an ally here that you're supporting
in this genocide uh you're spending
three how many almost four billion
dollars a year is this good for America
no I mean obviously I mean this is uh a
tragedy like the rest of the world is
laughing actually not laughing the rest
of the world is very angry at the United
States we've lost all credibility as a a
moral Force as a force of uh you know
anybody who could do any good you know
I'm been very critical of US foreign
policy for you know most of my life so
for many people across the world this is
not a surprise but I think for many who
held out hope that the United States had
been sort of this moral Force um the
mask is off and unfortunately um they've
seen sort of this this darker side trust
has gone you know like any relationship
once trust is gone it takes a very very
long time to rebuild so um we're the Bad
Guy like to be frank the United States
right now the United States government
and its military are the bad guys uh and
it's pretty clear to see so um that's
not good in another way though I mean
there's always opportunity and there's
always a silver lining it's never too
late to turn back people are starting to
wake up even if the media and the
politicians haven't come around yet many
of the people in the United States of
America especially on social media
they've seen through the lies of the
Zionist sort of propaganda machine
they've understood they've switched
sides they've noticed that this doesn't
make any sense and they're very
conscientious people we saw Jewish voice
for peace taking over Grand Central
Station uh in New York City we've seen
other people do actions I think in
Boston at a Israeli sort of uh weapons
company or something like that so there
are people of conscience and there are
always people of conscience that want to
do the right thing and we invite people
to have that Reckoning and be on the
right side of history and to do whatever
you can to speak up and to redeem right
redeem your country save your country if
your country a lot of people they they
they want to make this seem like it's
treachery or a lack of loyalty it's not
a lack of loyalty when you want to fix
something that's bad if you see your
nation or your government or something
doing something that's absolutely
horribly wrong then it's actually your
loyalty to it to try to step in and fix
it and um you know Muslims adopt that
position and also non-muslims in the
United States are adopting that position
as well I am pissed you know why I'm
pissed because I am an American I am an
American citizen with an American
opinion on what is happening right now
and there are millions of Americans like
me that are furious at this genocide we
are Furious and we are Furious that the
United States is paying for these bombs
we are Furious and you know what you
know what I'm not on American news I'm
not on CNN I'm not on Fox News I'm not
on MSNBC I'm nowhere on American News
even though I'm an American with an
American
opinion and I'm pissed I'm pissed you
are doing us a diservice you are doing
the citizens of an of America a
disservice and the citizens of the world
a disservice because you are not
reporting the truth America you are not
reporting the truth you are reporting
only one side one set of
opinions and you are telling the world
this is what America thinks no it's not
no it's not there are millions of us who
condemn this
genocide put me on
TV put me on CNN put me on Fox News let
me tell the world that there is a
different kind of American that does not
believe in this genocide I'm done with
your
lies if you're an American and you're
pissed and you're done with the lies of
media demand that they put our opinions
on TV Tag tag CNN tag MSNBC share there
are thousands of creators like me who
are on TV all over the Arab world
thousands of us and nowhere to be seen
in
America very very important and the
voices that are on the radios like uh we
were talking about Charlie Kirk it's
very important you know because you've
seen much of these um conservative radio
talk shows maybe they don't see what
kind of influence they have in a
negative way you had recently you had
this six-year-old boy right in my
backyard in Chicago where there at the
janaza the six-year-old boy when they
asked the his wife the person who who
killed him stabbed him 26 times and he
said he was listening to conservative
talk radio so you can imagine what was
going in his head and he had actually
years uh he had built the young boy a a
treehouse and so they he snapped
listening to this uh was he listening to
to Charlie Kirk was he listening to some
of the other people they got to think
before they speak how how important are
these words that are coming out most of
these These are Hal truths lies
misinformation they're going to be
accountable if they believe in God yeah
no very true like I said I mean people
they owe it to themselves to be
exploratory right if that means that you
have to resist your hot take or resist
sort of your grand standing for a little
bit then so be it but the consequences
are very very uh grave and so everybody
should sort of be very very careful
before just getting up on a public
platform and making these bold
declarations this saber rattling this
sort of tough talk Macho Man stuff that
you're going to get people killed you're
going to get people killed and you know
God's
watching what do you tell people who
really have an elementary or no kind of
knowledge of the background and then
they hear you know just the typical
story okay you have a right to defend
yourself human Shields you know they
hear many of these aru these talking
points and it's from like it's the media
has just got their script and you know
they're giving half thecid of story and
average person is confused and you think
oh this is confusing it's gray area it's
like you know and they're reacting
according to what they're seeing like uh
how how can they get more informed on
this because it's pretty straightforward
if you just ask yourself you know
America the home of the free the home of
the brave you know Liberty freedom and
you know if you get somebody walking in
your
backyard and somebody for an inch of
property you're ready to take his head
off imagine if this was happening to you
put yourself in their shoes if you talk
about Freedom right what what would you
what would you say to them how could
they get more informed yeah I think one
of the best thing about the American
people is that we distrust Authority um
sometimes we go a little too far with
that but but in general you know
compared to other places around the
world we tend to distrust Authority so I
would just encourage everybody to be
consistent like I said you know it's
like you were you didn't believe the
news three weeks ago four weeks ago now
you believe everything they say you
didn't trust the president you know
three weeks ago four weeks ago now you
believe everything he says what's wrong
here right you're not being consistent
they've scared you they've spooked you
into uh basically drinking up their lies
right they say that Hamas is going to
come for you next and this is the old an
old trick that they use all the time
they beat the drums of War they try to
make you seem threatened once you seem
threatened and you and you're afraid of
some sort of takeover here or abroad or
something like that then you're going to
you're going to be much more gullible
right and American people don't like
being gullible they don't like being
fooled they don't like being tricked
well wake up you're being fooled you're
being tricked the same people that you
distrusted a month ago you're now
believing everything they said and
they've been caught lying and they've
had to apologize for lying so why would
you continue to believe these people you
have the story of the boy who cried wolf
at a certain point you have to stop
believing in the boy who cries wolf you
have to start thinking for yourself you
have to start investigating and you have
to start paying
attention uh Theodore Herzel you know
the name right yeah Theodore herzo uh is
it true he was an atheist
uh I don't know I'm not sure to be
honest this is from my re research it it
comes off that he was an atheist he's
the the person pretty much uh the the
prophet of this movement is it
rightfully so he's the person who
started this uh movement the Zionist
movement definitely one of the
architects of Zionism one of the one of
the Architects okay um I want to show
this next clip and is going to go into
my my next question you must remember
what AAL has done to you says our Holy
Bible and we do remember and we are
fighting our brave troops and combatants
who are now in Gaza or around Gaza and
in all other regions in
Israel are joining this chain of Jewish
Heroes a chain that has started 3,000
years ago okay so you see a lot of
people who are in this movement they're
pretty much secular uh they really don't
have a connection with uh even with the
Bible
and then now you see this person and
many are a atheists but he in this case
uh this prime minister he's now quoting
the Bible and he's using this EMC and
many people are just over their heads
you're quite familiar with comparative
religion and what not can you bring us
up to speed what's he what's kind of
message what's he sending here with the
AMC and then you have Samuel 1 uh I
believe verse 15 talking about going
into every town and annihilating
everyone right you even have some rabbis
on that side who are saying show no
mercy it's
unbelievable there is no permission from
the toat to have any Mercy
whatsoever during war not on children
not on women not on
anybody right what should we take away
from this well I think that we see uh a
classic case of secular movements and
secular governments using and
manipulating religion conscripting it
for its own ends right because if you go
to Orthodox Jews we are required to let
the world know that these zionists and
their state does not speak for the
Jewish people and they are not in any
way have the right to use Judaism to
oppress to steal the land from the
Palestinian people are these people who
are good to us and we babysat each
other's children we live together they
have no right to steal from them the
Torah doesn't permit you to steal Ultra
conservative Jews they're extremely
against Netanyahu they're extremely
against the Israeli regime uh the
Zionist regime to be more specific uh
and they have deep criticisms uh of of
them so but when you're dealing with a
certain population and this can happen
to Muslims it can happen to Christians
too right all of a sudden the Prime
Minister the president becomes uh a
scholar of EX aesus right where he uh he
Marshals his quotes from wherever he
needs to Marshal them and it's going to
justify his geopolitical ends or his
genocidal rage uh in this particular
case right but if he were to actually
submit himself to an international body
of scholarly Judaism you know they could
actually hold him to account for his his
interpretation or his misinterpretation
as many Orthodox Jews do right so this
is something that is making a mockery of
religion it's the conscription of
religious language in order to justify
Bloodshed it's actually the same exact
thing that uh Kirk accused that that
Kirk is engaged in or that he accuses
like Isis of engaging in which is just
the cherry-picking of certain texts to
justify whatever you want you know
anybody can go into a text and and
cherry pick to justify what they want to
do that doesn't necessarily mean it's
representative of the religion or that
that's a sound interpretation of that
text do you do you know much about this
group The emites the amales no you I
think you're more of a an expert in
those sorts of things than me yeah so
this this is at that time where the
there's a group of people that they went
to annihilate and we know in the Quran
God Almighty Allah is saying that woe to
those who write the book with their
hands and we know the previous
scriptures were changed altered would
you say with your experience that this
can be some of those verses that they're
trying to justify the killing of
innocent human beings in Islam it's
clear Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessing be upon him in the Quran in the
authentic Hadith Sunnah killing
non-combatants this is something that's
totally against Islam but here you have
a justification that they're giving now
it's coming out now it's like this
wasn't talked about before you didn't
hear this it's always Muslims making it
clear you cannot kill non-combatants
it's it's uh unjustifiable but now
they're actually getting the green light
from everybody from Christians everybody
go go go Prince of Peace just went out
the window now it's like war war war and
would you say with your experience that
this is one of those verse that has been
altered and changed to justify the
killing of innocent men women and
children yeah quite likely so I mean we
see all the time um let's put it this
way that in the modern era where faith
and religion sort of is understood as
just a a list of things that you believe
in right people have lost their
appreciation for how significant and
damaging it is to base your life off of
false Revelation and false guidance
right because false Revelation and false
guidance is going to error it's going to
be mistaken in One Direction or another
either it's going to be too permissive
or it's going to be too restrictive it's
going to be too soft or it's going to be
too hard right so when people insert
themselves and they write the scriptures
themselves and they contaminate the
guidance of God with their own words
their own thoughts and their own ideas
it's going to have serious consequences
down the line we could make a same sort
of similar analogy with with
Christianity and you know you go back to
the doctrine of discovery which uh you
know was issued in the late 1400s by the
Pope that said basic basically that any
Christian if you come across land
belonging to quote a Saron or a pagan
that meant Muslims or Native Americans
then it's yours to take right and this
is not something buried in the ancient
past this is something that was
referenced as recently as 2008 by Ruth
Bader Ginsburg uh in a Supreme Court
case against the Onida Indians in our
neck of the woods up here in central New
York right so these things actually have
significant consequences you have
somebody who forges something or inserts
something into Revelation thousands of
years ago and now thousands of years
later people are going to use it to
justify Bloodshed or whatever they want
to accomplish so having authentic
Revelation is extremely significant much
more than people
realize there's a great documentary um
called uh the nakba of tentura have you
heard of this have you seen that
documentary I have not seen the
documentary but I've heard of it yeah
I'm I'm trying to uh find this
documentary to watch I watched some
clips from it and I was looking into
this and I think it's a very important
documentary for people to watch it
actually revolves around an Israeli who
went and did interviews with much of the
soldiers at that time in
1948 and then they went after him and
they threatened him and they pretty much
made him come and retract this and say
he was lying after he did extensive
amount of
investigation and improved what you're
talking about land grab rape killing
murder babies in ovens you know the
stuff that they're repeating now it's
like you're talking that reection
literally the man is testifying that he
saw with his own eyes that the Israeli
the soldier told this mother to throw or
the hus father and mother throw the baby
in the oven he's testifying to this and
then he took the baby through it in the
oven and then threw her in the oven and
and this is a testimony that's in this
documentary and it's not a Muslims who's
making this documentary this is is Jews
who are making this doc this this
documentary so it's very powerful to
show like that these were at that time
if you can talk to our audience just a
little bit from what you know what was
happening because they they make it seem
like this is just now at that time a
defenseless people defending themselves
you had all these Arab countries come in
attack and and that's the impression
that the American public get they were
just defending themselves right no you
have to you have to realize at this
point that every Zionist accusation is a
confession um and when it came to I
think you can draw a a distinct line
from how you know when Jews first
started migrating to Palestine they were
welcomed with open arms and in fact no
place perhaps on earth except maybe
Muslim Spain has a better track record
of peaceful coexistence of Christians
and Jews and Muslims um but in 1948 you
know whatever justification that they
used for it um was an immense ethnic
cleansing an immense genocide an immense
bloodletting an immense uh dispossession
of people from their lands uh kicking
them out stealing their stuff is just
absolute brutality
um and so this is something that they
celebrate as the founding of the nation
you know which is that's what makes it
actually a sensitive topic in the United
States because you know one could argue
that there are similar sort of events
that were part of the founding of the of
the United States as well and so it's
actually uh historically very similar so
if you go to a university in the United
States and you see these so-called land
de declarations where people sort of
give lip service to the fact that
they're on they believe that they're on
land and this mostly applies to people
on the left who care about this sort of
stuff you know there's a land there's a
land grab going on right now right and
it's been going on you know in your
lifetime and in your parents lifetimes
and you actually have the opportunity to
stop it right the question is some
people you know again this mostly
applies to people on the left they
almost wished that they had lived at a
time um where some some some of these
things were going on so that they could
have supposedly stop it well guess what
you're living at a time where this is
actually going on so are you going to
step up and stop it can can you make a
contrast I mean uh just something
similar so the American public can
understand uh where you have right now
they're freaking out you have people
sleeping in in in police stations I
don't know if you've seen I've seen with
my own eyes you have the the open
borders and they're going crazy with
this and uh imagine now the migrants
come and they're you you take few and
you you want to be uh someone who's
compassionate you bring them in your
house you feed them you take care of
them and next thing you know after a few
years they put you in the basement yeah
it's the ultimate gratitude and this is
something lots of people have talked
about I mean you just gave the example I
mean nobody would accept um this type of
of treatment um and if anybody were in
this situation then they don't know what
they would do to be honest they don't
know to what extent their desperation
would reach that would they be able to
control themselves or would they go
absolutely berserk with their with their
sense of Injustice and indignity um
because to welcome in a people with open
arms and to you know be willing to to to
be a refuge for them and then to
actually have them turn on you in the
most brutal and and bloody way possible
um to the point where it's not just
about grabbing the land it's just not
settling for anything short of complete
extermination and removal right this is
something that is um incredibly damning
incredibly damning um and it's something
that nobody would tolerate uh tell us uh
having a political science degree uh you
are someone who can give us uh your
perspective of what does it look like is
this something that now can lead to a
World War I is this something that
um what are your thoughts well I'm more
of a political theorist than an analyst
so I'm not going to make any bold uh
predictions but you know anything is
possible Right you see what's happening
now things are moving very quickly um we
have the Declaration from the hois
yesterday that they're you know
officially declaring war we have erdogan
who said that you know if other Regional
actors are willing to cooperate that
maybe he's willing to do something it's
kind of like um this moment where
everybody's staring at each other and
and who's G to Flinch first um so we
don't know what's G to happen I mean
anything is possible I think that just
focusing on us here in the US or in the
west like what we're capable of doing um
you know public opinion does matter it
still does matter and expressing your
public opinion you know Expos ing the
lies of the Zionist propaganda on social
media uh holding people accountable in
the media Representatives people you
know um trying to swing in to support
and save people who have been fired from
their jobs for being pro Palestine or
trying to be doxed at a university or
things like that um you know attempting
to basically make as much noise as
possible we've seen a we've seen a big
shift to be frank in the rhetoric that's
been coming out of us politicians and Us
Media sources it's still very messed up
but we have seen a shift so if we
continue to to keep pressing um we have
hope that uh we will be able to actually
achieve some sort of change I know we
have a a nationwide demonstration that's
happening in Washington DC this weekend
coming up on Saturday um and the one
demand is simple uh ceasefire now right
now that's not to say that this is going
to solve everything you know the problem
is the occupation but definitely when it
comes to what has to happen immediately
um you know the the Zionist regime has
to stop attacking people in Gaza and
people in Palestine and general and then
also we need to have we need to stop
sending you know our tax dollars our
money for their you know this complete
blank check for their Slaughter right
and until we're able to stop it somehow
we fear that we are going to be
accountable in front of God for uh being
complicit in these sorts of things so we
just have to keep pressing on keep
fighting the fight and hopefully at
least start to see it would be a major
victory um if we were able to achieve a
ceasefire in the short term and then
from there sort of assess our options
and see how far we can press this
thing yeah they try to uh when you look
at some of the uh mainstream media
channels especially I'm like surprised
Fox News they Tred to um they try to
paint a picture as people who are
protesting practicing their
constitutional right for freedom of
speech
and at the same time they were
criticizing that they were being
cancelled when they were speaking
against wokeism and all the other stuff
but now they want to ca cancel this
freedom of speech for people of who are
trying to save the innocent children
they're trying to connect them to a
political party hamus what you know most
people Muslims don't even know these
political groups they just see they're
just concerned about the innocent you
got Christians also innocent you know
Christians Muslims who are being
oppressed who are being carpet bombed
it's like Mo the lawn like are you out
of your mind like you know so that's can
you comment on that what do these
protests have you seen this that they
try to paint this picture no that's the
that's their Last Stand because you know
the the it's it's reached a a level of
Hysteria where and and the Zionist
regime is very shrewd about this from
the beginning they've tried to say that
you know Hamas equals Isis and you know
people who support Hamas or even any way
sympathetic to the P like Hamas is Gaza
right and then anyone who's supportive
of Gaza is supportive of Hamas is
supportive of Isis that's the the the
narrative that they've tried to spin
from day one so this is sort of The Last
Stand of some people in the West trying
to win the information war or win the
Battle of narratives trying to say you
know we had even in the UK the
demonstrations that have been going on
some of the MPS and some of the the
people in government saying that this is
a March of hate uh some people on the US
side saying that this is the same as um
and these are Democrats saying this
saying saying that uh this is the same
as the white supremacists marching in
Virginia these sorts of things this is
their last stand I don't think that they
have a game plan past this so if we're
able to call it out if we're able to
push back and uh and contradict it and
win the information war and prove to
people that this is ridiculous it's
McCarthyism uh it's it's a Witch Hunt
it's completely not based in fact
whatsoever um we have a chance of of
prevailing um but we have to uh but we
have to really really um fight this
narrative history shows when Muslims
were the victors when they came into uh
Jerusalem and they were ruling how
Muslims treated and gave rights to the
Jews to Christians you even had the
Christians who are showing how Muslims
were protecting the churches holding the
keys Abid Judah he's entrusted with the
key to the Church of the Holy Seer it is
one of the holiest sites in Christianity
and its key belongs to a Muslim family a
neutral Guardian for a site sacred to so
many Christian denominations the
contracts for the guardian of the key
date back hundreds of years this is the
key to one of the Holy Place holiest
places in Christianity and every morning
this key opens the door this key open
the door for 500 years for more than 850
[Music]
years
to these uh churches for hundreds of
years so historically Muslims have set
the presidents how to treat treat other
people of other faiths uh so how do you
answer this question when it comes up
that the Jews now are fighting for
survival the chance River to the Sea
they just want to we have to do this to
protect our existence yeah this is
Zionist propaganda the the biggest
threat to the Jewish people is the
Zionist regime it's not Muslim
if you were to get rid of the Zionist
regime then the Muslims and Jews could
get along right but that's not what they
want because they want genocide and they
want extermination and they want their
land right so I mean if you go yeah
exactly as you said in
history he you know was the first to
conquer Palestine and Conquer Jerusalem
one of the first things he did was
protect a church he refused to pray
Salah in a church because he was afraid
that later generations of Muslims would
come and take it over and make it into a
mid he didn't want that that's how
careful he was to protect the Christian
that were under his responsibility one
of the first things he did was allow the
Jews to come back again like I've said
that the expulsion and hatred of the
Jews is a European Christian problem
right every time the the Christians took
over the holy lands they kicked out the
Jews right the only times that that the
Jews have been able to sustain
themselves or to have an amicable sort
of peaceful existence since the time of
Jesus was when the Muslims were in
control right Omar lets the Jews back
into Jerusalem they had been banned by
the Christians before him then when the
Christians came over and take and took
over Jerusalem and the Crusades they
they kicked out the Jews again and then
once salahadin came and liberated
Jerusalem he let the Jews back in right
so nobody has any leg to stand on when
it comes to educating Muslims on how to
treat other people who are different
from us we are the exemplars we are the
ahead of the curve we are the ones that
you should take lessons from right so
this is all just a false narrative to
get people to be afraid when we say from
The River To The Sea we mean the Zionist
regime has to go we mean the occupation
has to go they're afraid because they're
projecting their accusations are
confessions they are afraid because if
they remove the is the Israeli
government they assume that the
Palestinian people are going to do the
same to them that they have done to the
Palestinians and it couldn't be further
from the truth if they were to remove
the the Zionist regime and the
government and even the state of Israel
if the state of Israel were to be
dissolved tomorrow the Palestinian would
be the most hospitable people to the
Jews and the other people the Israelis
who are there but they're afraid because
they have a guilty conscience because
they know what they've done so it's uh
it's very straightforward the Muslim
Palestinians uh they want to live
together in peace just don't oppress us
and take our land I mean that's not too
much to ask for is it pry yeah don't
don't like many IDF soldiers they've
confessed break into the silence people
can go ahead and look at some of these
confessions have you seen these where
they testimony they're coming out they
said we get paid this is our job to have
our presence on the back of their necks
can you imagine that they they're great
they do he's doing graveyard shift and
it's to go in just a home random homes
and to go in there and just make their
presence F you know terrorize families
and without any notice without any
invitation came into the apartment and
have' been there ever
since canot speak with you there's a
soldiers there soldiers yes what are
they doing here we are prison here
what's happening they are keep keeping
here and soldiers upstairs we cannot
move we cannot speak with you you can't
leave the house they told you that yes I
can't breathe how long are they going to
stay I don't know are they paying you
any money you are kidding I'm Kidd Abdul
the bank manager said he had to get to
his bank to open the safe but the sold
won't let him go he told us when the
soldiers come they wake everybody up and
her them into a kitchen for hours while
soldiers sleep in their bedrooms they
can't leave or use the phone or let us
in he sent us downstairs to see if his
brother would open the
door so we could ask the soldiers why
they keep taking over this house you
want to come yes
uh just open the door and then the house
they Clos the soldiers closed the
door from the
keys they they take the keys so we left
and that night so did the soldiers but
when we returned 2 Days Later the
soldiers were back for more surveillance
this time they kept the women under
house arrest but let the men go to work
and the children go to school when the
children returned we caught a glimpse of
two armed soldiers at the top of the
stairs
then more children came
home but the soldiers wouldn't open the
door again they say if you don't go back
behind the wall the children will not
enter the house but this is where the
children live yeah but you need to go
away from the door so I can let the
children come in okay who are
you he's a commander here he's a
commander here can we talk to you no
well we're talking to you now why don't
you tell us what you're doing
here have you lost your
voice well they've closed the door now
they've closed the window so I guess um
if the children are going to get home we
have to um we have to leave how would
you feel yeah no absolutely and we saw
similar things with the war in Iraq
right some of the US soldiers that were
there they have there's there's
consequences there's symptoms that
people have mental breakdowns people
have you know psychological trauma from
being forced into a situation where
you're the oppressor and you will always
find the centers right and that's what
people should also pay attention to
where are the M you know the denters
coming from you know the denters are
coming from the IDF people who have
conscience people who want to do the
right thing where you see that um they
know what they've done and they know
what everything is you have so many
people coming out and speaking out
against the IDF and speaking out against
the Zionist regime because they want to
do the right thing right um and so
people should any neutral party would
evaluate this and say okay the vast
majority of the noise that is expressing
sort of doubt and dissent and regret um
are people from the the ex you know IDF
soldiers and ex people people who used
to be part of the the Zionist regime and
so what does that tell you you know that
tells you really everything that you
need to know and this is uh very
straightforward this is not a je Muslim
Jewish thing this is you've uh clear
that this is not a like they try to make
it make people believe no of course not
no but how could it be when there are
Jews that are against Israel there are
Jews that are anti-zionists there are
Jews that um support the Palestinian
cause right are all of them just
brainwashed self-hating Jews like that
makes no sense at all right no this is
another propaganda trick that they have
to sort of rely upon uh in order to
justify their Slaughter uh we hear this
often that this is the only true
democracy in the area there so can you I
mean this is just like unbelievable so
you have two sets of laws for two people
and even Israelis and Jewish people will
come out and talk about this but for the
average person again just kind of paint
that picture you got no go they talk
about noo zones you've he recently um a
politician in Florida making this
statement uh the governor there I was
very shocked and surprised there's these
are no go zones in UK and America you
know France or something no such thing
these are lies but these are actual noo
zones the is that correct like in these
areas you have IDF soldiers talking
about that this is a road you can't go
down there if you're non-jew I've been
there it's an apartheid system I was
allowed to use one road why other people
weren't I was allowed to have water why
other people weren't not right yeah and
then and then and then you have a right
a return for someone who's in New York y
I just I just blows my mind just talking
about this so you're coming from you
never visited a place but somebody who's
who's been there his ancestors have been
there they lived there they were forced
out in the NBA yeah that they're not
allowed to talk about uh now it's
illegal to talk about it but now they
want to come back they can't come back
but the person from New York New Jersey
or Chic wherever the case they can come
yeah no I mean nobody nobody hates
democracy more than the Zionist regime
like that's just uh I think that's
obvious they're terrified of democracy
because if they were to give equal
status to the Palestinians like this is
why they would never support a one-state
solution and I'm not saying that the one
solution is a good idea but why you
never hear anything about the one state
solution is because if you have to give
all the Palestinians an equal vote to
the you know to the to everybody else
who's there then the Zionist sort of
government would dissolve it would be
nonsensical the Constitution would have
to be changed you know uh everything
would have to change because the state
of Israel as it is constructed is a
terrorist Zionist ethnos supremacist
racist State that's in the law that's
just in the Constitution it's in the
laws of the land
right um so they're terrified of
democracy because they're terrified of
democracy until obviously one of their
tactics is to play these population
games try to expel as many uh
Palestinians as possible so that one day
hopefully they think they'll have a
majority and then they can Embrace
democracy but right now democracy is is
the last thing on their minds because
they're afraid of what would happen if
Palestinians actually had voting
power I want to thank you uh Imam Tom
thank you very much and uh people uh one
last
thing we as Muslims we
believe in all the prophets many that
are mentioned in the bible we believe in
Jesus we love Jesus and it's unfortunate
it's a really strange relationship uh
between these uh zionists and the um the
Christians there you know they're being
spit on you know they're uh pretty much
uh just being humiliated there and
Muslims with open arms I mean are
welcoming you know Christians they have
rights you know according to the Sharia
is this correct you know that are
guarded you can't take them away uh
they're not talking about beheading
Christians if they were in charge I mean
this is another another myth so are
these people actually following the true
teachings of Moses no of course not no
and and and Christians are are
especially sort of blameworthy here
because you know we've got a group of
people who believes in Jesus and loves
Jesus and and reveres Jesus right even
if have disagreements about who he is
and then you've got you know other
people who they think that Jesus was a
false prophet and they you know think
that he should have been put to death
right so who I mean just from a logical
perspective who who would be a more
natural Ally you would think which is
why I said what I said before is that
Christians most Christians in America
they're not seriously Christians they're
they're nationalists their Christianity
has been secularized and domesticated by
the nation state and they're you know
nationalists first and Christianity is
just sort of something that's just
cultural and it's it's used for you know
justification but we challenge people we
challenge people if you really believe
in God if you really believe in the
Bible you know then you should take
these things seriously and you should
never put your own government above uh
above criticism right you should hold
your government to standards of the
faith that you believe in and if you do
that we believe that you will come
around and you will see that the truth
right here in this situation is with the
Palestinians and the Palestinian cause
hey Mom Tom thank you so much uh for
spending some time with with us uh
shedding some clarity and light on the
situation hopefully for people who are
sincere they genuinely want to know the
truth this has shed a lot of light on it
and they can uh come if Charlie Kirk or
any of these other conservative uh talk
shows or whatnot they want to have an
Imam Imam Tom uh born bred in America
American raised they want to find out
why he accepted Islam submission to the
Creator not the creation they want to
know more about the situation they can
come and visit you invite you on yeah
definitely you see how easy that was
guys Kurt go visit visit him uh and and
all the other people before you go ahead
make a a statement or you uh spread any
more the hate go ahead and connect with
the
Muslims thank you very much thanks so
much for having me
on brothers and sisters we've all had
loved ones that passed away a mother a
father a brother sister a close family
member but one of the mercies of our
Dean is that with the right intention we
can go ahead and continue to do good
deeds on our love 's behalf and what
greater of a continuous Good Deed s than
investing on their behalf in the deed
Center a mid and mega dawa Center that
will benefit generations to come
inshallah so click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you I cannot leave without giving
you a gift if you're not yet Muslim and
you tuning in to see what these Muslims
are talking about and you like a free
copy of the Quran go ahead and visit
theen show.com we'll take care of the
postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at 1 1800
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alikum